[Applause] The
number of articles I read on the Internet yesterday: The
3rd place in the list of girl's gestures that make men's hearts flutter: The 2nd place is the
gesture of flipping one's hair up, the 1st place is the
upward look, and the 1st place is the
gesture of tugging at it. Don't take
such
Internet articles with a grain of
salt.  Don't do it, I'm so shocked.Despite the fact that I'm
so nervous, I'm actually a senior.I'm not really
surprised.I was just
surprised because he pulled me so suddenly.Look, I
wasn't surprised.It was a
little shocking at first, but on the
other hand, this is Nagatoro's sleeve.  If you grab it, you
can suppress the movement. I've been
doing this since early morning
[Music]